Zoro is one of the most monstrous
characters in one piece but is he
actually strong enough to beat most of
Luffy's enemies provided that he can
find them first let's put it to the test
and up first is iron mace Alva and yeah
I don't think we even need to talk about
this one it's pretty much a wash and up
next is hel Meo again no problem if
we're being real if Zoro took out his
dad ex and Morgan Mr butchin is going to
be no problem whatsoever as well and
finally we do get a real thread though
which is Moji the lion tamer and Richie
the lion just kidding I mean Zoro beat
buggy second in command Kaji here even
though he had a terrible Stab Wound so
I'm pretty sure that these guys are
going to be no problem for Zoro
whatsoever just like they were no
problem whatsoever for Luffy as well but
now we do have a real problem in our
hands which is buggy because Buggy's
Chop Chop fruit is a heart counter to
anything that zaro can do and since this
fight would be taking place in the east
blue hockey is not a real Factor here no
matter how much Zoro Cuts buggy up he
would be completely unharmed so in this
specific matchup zaro would actually
just be wrecked and honestly depending
on whether bogy has in the meantime
picked up some hockey skills Zoro might
not be able to take him out right now in
the final Saga since the fruit is just
such a hard counter for his sword skills
however Zoro would absolutely stomp
Captain Kudo I mean yeah Kudo is fast
but these claws are pretty much swords
and Zoro isn't losing a sword battle to
this clown I mean cat I guess now with
Don Creek we actually have to make a
special consideration because did Zoro
still get obliterated by mihawk right
before this battle and actually for the
sake of discussion at zoro's full
strength we're going to say that Zoro
gets to fight all of these next
antagonists without being mortally
wounded SL unconscious and I would say
at full strength even in these blue Zoro
clears dong Creek easy and it really
doesn't even matter matter how many toys
Creek brings out because he's not
standing up to a good Slash from the W
ichimonji and it's actually a similar
story with arlong in the story as is
Zoro didn't stand a chance there because
his wound from mihawk reopened however
even with this wound he devastated Hai
and so zoro's reputation was so renowned
that arlong actually thought the rest of
the crew was working for him not only
that but when he saw how Zoro was
fighting even with a wound that should
have killed him arlong saw him as enough
of a threat that he wanted to dispose of
him right then and there and so had Zoro
been at full strength I think arlong
wouldn't have stood a chance against
Zoro as well however Captain smoker here
is a big loia shaped problem because
just like with buggy the swords simply
are not going to work here so just like
his captain Zoro is basically useless
against smoker at this point once again
the crew's best bet is to flee from low
toown as fast as possible now if the
characters were to fight in the current
story smoka wouldn't stand even a minute
now that Zoro has Armament haki and can
also cut loia devil fruit users and so
really now this Marine's Powers would
just make him an even bigger Target for
Zoro Mr F and Miss Valentine were a joke
they were trying their best to fight
against Zoro and Luffy while the two
crew mates fought against each other at
most they maybe amounted to an annoying
distraction and when it came time to
take them out they were no problem at
all so Zoro could probably take them on
one by one like he took out the rest of
whiskey Peak Mr three the Waxman would
actually be a bit of a struggle I think
in the story as it was written Zoro did
get trapped and immobilized by the wax
however he was perfectly willing to cut
off his own legs in order to continue
the battle now luckily Luffy showed up
in time to save zoro's legs but even
legless Zoro would have cut Mr 3 down no
question about it okay listen wle was
lucky that Zoro slept through most of
drum Island also since wle was basically
threatening Chopper's home and according
to the one piece fandoms Zoro is pretty
much Chopper that at this point this
fight would have been very personal so
no contest at all and next we do have
another loia just like smoker crocodile
is going to be pretty much intangible to
Zoro sword strikes he may have figured
out how to cut steel during his fight
with da bones which does suggest Zoro
tapped into armenaki however Zoro was
barely clinging to Life by the end of
that battle and I've got a feeling that
he wouldn't last nearly as long against
a warlord at this point in the story Kar
on the other hand probably not a problem
now Bellamy on the other hand still gets
one shot except instead of getting his
lights punched out of him the dude would
probably just get cut in half as for the
god of lightning NL well I don't have to
think about that one too hard because
Oda already showed us this fight
happening all it really took in the
story was a few lightning strikes to
take out our favorite swordsman it is
actually kind of hard to tell how zoro's
current Armament hockey level would
affect this fight because with metal
swords being able to conduct electricity
would his attacks just hurt him back
maybe once enl finally gets back from
the Moon we'll see a rematch that will
tell us how exactly this Clash would
play out right now but I would still be
inclined to give that to current Zoro
and now of course for zoro's most
threatening opponent so far Foxy the
Silver Fox how can Zoro ever hope to
contend with Foxy's slow slow beam n
just just kidding Foxy's getting cut up
pretty easily the only question is would
we get a afro Zoro I mean Sanji would
probably have a field day with how much
he'd look like an actual mimo in that
case now Kuan is not getting cut up easy
though Zoro at the end of long ring Long
Long Island would get flash frozen just
like luff and Robin I mean probably K
zaro also would have a hard time against
aiji but he might have a decent chance
at this point at least and I know that
this is going to upset some of the power
scalers in the community but I'm going
to go out on a limp here and say that
Zoro is stronger than Uso yeah I know
and unlike Luffy who was filled with
regret at having to fight his crewmate
Zoro was cold as ice when it came to
Uso's betrayal and wouldn't hesitate at
all to wipe the floor with him I'd say
now Frankie here would have a way better
shot than Uso his cyborg body is quite
durable after all but as established in
alabasta Zoro has no problem now cutting
through steel and actually during Anna's
Lobby Zoro was able to defeat Kaku who
is a much stronger zp9 member than Bruno
therefore Bruno's going down no matter
how many TI eyes he pulls out however it
is kind of doubtful that Zoro could have
actually taken on Rob Luchi during the
water 7 Arc I mean it took everything
Zoro had to defeat Kaku who's
significantly weaker than Luchi and so
Zoro would have put up a very good fight
but in the end probably couldn't have
squeezed out a win here thankfully
though EAD Island showed us just how
much Zoro has grown throughout the time
Skip and through wano by giving us
exactly this matchup that we never knew
that we need it Luchi has grown enough
to awaken his leopard devil fruit but
Zoro has become the right-hand man of a
literal emperor of the sea powerful
enough to fight the strongest zp0 agents
also Zoro totally could have defeated
geeko Modia in a one versus one though
after all later on when nothing happened
Zoro took on all that pain that Luffy
had experienced throughout the battle
and was still standing up so it really
makes me wonder though what it would
have been like to get a nightmare Zoro
let's say during forar okay and next up
is s Charlos and hear me out like
obviously any character like even
Chopper or Uso could beat this Celestial
Dragon in a fight however I'm going to
give Zoro a lost by technicality here
because after Bonnie told him what's up
with trying to get in the way of a
Celestial Dragon he took the hint unlike
his captain zoro's not quite stupid
enough to call down a literal Marine
Admiral and the full force of the world
government on his crew so we're going to
say that that he won't even get involved
in this fight in the first place now on
the island of Amazon Lily Luffy was
thrust into a battle with boa hanock
sisters marold and sandersonia
ultimately he overcame them by unlocking
his conqueror hockey and Zoro would have
just overcome them using his sords
however during the impal down Prison
Break zaro would not at all get over
mellin with his sords much like Luffy he
would probably just get super poisoned
also like Luffy though he has incredible
amounts of willpower and durability so
he could probably survive thanks to
Ivanov and live to fight another day at
Marine Fort where he just like Luffy
would completely obliterate Kobe sorry
Kobe you've gotten real strong and
everything but you're not quite there
yet pre time skip I think and GARP on
the other hand is not going to allow
himself to get hit like he did by his
grandson though so Zoro is getting
Galaxy fisted and after his 2-year
recovery from that Galaxy punch though
he'll still be ready to oneshot some
posy fistas at the return to to sabba
Odi just like Luffy did and we also
conveniently know just how the fight
with hodi Jones would go because Zoro
already fought him during the fisherman
island arc granted he wasn't on his
overdose of energy steroids quite yet
but even with that power up Zoro had
still defeated him underwater once and
could do it again if he wanted to he he
could probably even beat him a lot more
effectively than Luffy since Luffy was a
devil fruit user who had to deal with
being in the ocean and uh look out
Caesar Clown because unlike with the
other loia fruit users on this list so
far Zoro has Armament haki right now so
it doesn't matter how many weapons off
mass destruction Caesar has because the
W ichimonji is a bigger weapon of mass
destruction in zoro's hands also early
INR Rosa's Colosseum battles Luffy does
one-hot his future Ally hydrogen and so
would Zoro Don chin jaao here with his
master of conquas hockey would be a
little bit of a tougher battle since we
don't see Zoro use conquas hockey until
wano because because it is kind of
Uncertain when he actually unlocks this
ability however I will still be giving
Zoro the victory because I mean if he
beat Pika I'm pretty sure that he can
beat a pointy old man as well and Zoro
would even put up a very solid fight
against dony hoto Flamingo after all
even Sanji was strong enough during
dress Rosa to earn a compliment from the
most flamboyant of the Warlords Sanji
wasn't enough to make do Flamingo sweat
but the warlord did acknowledge his
power and if he thinks that Sanji is
strong then he'd probably also be
impressed with zoro's fighting ability
as well however it did take gear for
Luffy in the end to be able to overcome
this sort of monster and sadly Zoro
isn't taking out doflamingo at this
stage I think because if Zoro wasn't
even able to cut up the strings that
made up the bird cage I don't think he
has a chance against the warlord's
complete devil fruit Mastery especially
his Awakening but what about Curren Zar
though postano zaro would be a whole
different story with the insane power of
enma Not only would Zoro slice right
through the bird cage like butter he
would slice right through doflamingo
himself I mean sure doflamingo has a lot
of practice at stitching himself back
together with his strength string fruit
but he's going to have to do it a whole
lot faster if he wants to avoid getting
diced by zoro's Advanced conquas hocky
also at the end of Dres Rosa Luffy also
briefly clashed with fujit to and while
fujitora is likely a candidate for a
late game Zoro opponent Dr Rosa Zoro at
least would put up a good fight but
would ultimately be defeated if they
finish the battle nonetheless we
definitely want to see this Manch up
happening and now that Luffy is a yonko
and the strats are more directly
fighting against the world government
this is a fight that most fans
definitely want to see happen I mean we
anime fans are pretty simple creatures
we love it when guys fight with swords
and meters I guess now Zoro having
trouble with the flamingo also doesn't
bode well for him going up against big
mom's kids Luffy was only able to defeat
CER by eating his way through the
biscuits with his elastic stomach and
Zoro would not have had the same
Advantage can eat but not quite like
Luffy so it's just a question of whether
he'd be able to make it through
Cracker's super solid biscuit defenses
and while before wano it might have been
a close call now that he has enma he
could definitely easily cut through but
at the time of hul kick Islands maybe he
could have won there not sure about it
and of course zaro at hul cake Island
wouldn't have had future side either and
Charlotte kakur is a crazy strong
character who ended up essentially
drawing his match with Luffy as he
gained a respect for the straw head
captain but of course now that zaro has
been able to defeat King here it is very
likely that he'd be able to defeat the
other top yonko Commander as well
however I do think that katak Curry's
abilities would prove more of a
challenge for Zoro to overcome than King
as you might remember King depended a
lot on his Ultra durable lunarian skin
to tank zaro's attacks however katakuri
used a combination of future side
predictions and moving his malleable
Mochi body out of the way in order to
avoid Luffy's punches and due to how
sticky kataku Mochi actually is it's
also possible that he could manage to
disarm Zoro by having his sword stick in
his Mochi so honestly this would be a
fight to actually see happen one day but
now that katakuri will likely be a straw
hat Ally in some way or form it's
definitely unlikely that these two will
ever Clash in the future however now
that Zoro has awakened Advanced
conqueror hockey and was able to scar
the ultra durble kaido Zoro could
probably even cut through katakuri's
sticky Mochi so the real question is
whether he'd be fast enough to actually
beat katakuri's future site in this
hypothetical Battle of the yonko first
mes though we'd have to give it to Karo
I think because honestly tanking the
combined attack from big mom and kaido
means that he'd very much be able to
hold his on against any hit that
katakuri could potentially deliver all
while waiting for his opening moment to
cut down the Mochi man on wano though
things do do get a little bit better
kaido's F underlings like urashima and
hold him would be easily defeated just
as they were by Luffy and actually now
that he has a new power up in enma Zoro
becomes significantly stronger he would
be able to defeat ulti easily since he
was able to defeat King as well the
strongest of the flying six and then we
actually saw how well Zoro can actually
hold himself against two former yonko
bigmom and kaido during roof piece now
sadly enough these absolute units are
just too much for zaro to
single-handedly take down at this point
I'd say however he did tap into Advance
conqueror hockey and was actually able
to wound kaido himself now that's the
most that he was able to do during the
Battle of onigashima but what about Zoro
at the end of the series after all there
were plenty of Zoro fans who were really
devastated that our favorite swordsman
did not land the finishing blow on kaido
and so by the end of the series zaro
will be a second in command worthy of
the new pirate king strong enough to
even give mon monsters like kaido and
big mom a really hard time after all as
a distant descendant of theuma dragon
slaying is in zoro's blood and when Oda
revealed in an SPS that Zoro is in fact
a descendant from wano and therefore is
related to the legendary Samurai whose
zomie he fought on thrill bark it all
but confirms that it's zoro's Destiny to
have the power to defeat dragons like
kaido in the future after all ryuma was
the star of oda's pre- One Piece oneshot
manga wanted in which the samurai
actually slays a monstrous dragon as
well oda's no stranger to bringing back
characters that we long suspected to be
dead so if kaido ever crawls up out of
that volcano while Luffy's busy with emo
or something it'll be up to Zoro to take
him out a second time and if kaido ever
returns to face Zoro he will be ready
having massive the power of enma and
perhaps even having created a Black
Blade of his very own because let's be
real by the end of the series it only
makes sense for the pirate King's
right-hand man to be yonko level as well
and honestly that's going to be
necessary because it's only a matter of
time time before he goes head-to-head
with Draco mihawk the world's greatest
swordsman right now in fact mihawk is
such a formidable enemy that even the
insanely powerful Zoro at this point is
going to need a new power boost before
the end before he's able to take on his
mentor so will he just get a new sword
even stronger than enma will he turn the
W ichimonji into a black blade or will
Oda surprise us all by giving our
favorite green-haired swordsman the
power of an actual devil fruit and now
you might ask what devil fruit power
could possibly be the perfect fit to
give Zoro well you're in luck because
you can find the answer in this video
right here Shanks for watching